across Beirut across Lebanon something
remarkable seems to be having their
chant is a call for change we demand the
downfall of the regime they sing it is
the old rallying cry of the Arab Spring
but it is a 20-19 remix for Lebanon not
Muslim not Christian Lebanese they shout
this country wide movement it is an
unprecedented demonstration of unity and
under the national flag no religious
divides no political affiliation this is
a one nation protest a revolution
they're calling it through the morning
exhaustion from days of this left the
streets almost empty but pockets of
protesters soon gathered here in the
Hamra district sandwiched in between the
Interior Ministry and the central bank
Ali is 33 degrees no job for six years
six years outside Lebanon I came back
because I want to live here and my
country I don't wanna live once I don't
want to live outside my countdown I live
inside my country I want to live like
any normal citizen I want to have a job
I want to have a career I wanna live
here happily across the city roads are
spontaneously closed by the protesters
in another neighborhood the army were
blocking their movement but there has so
far been no attempt by the government to
shut down this mass movement yet the
Prime Minister's reforms announced on
Monday haven't done what he'd hoped they
are not nearly enough the people want
the whole government removed we're not
accepting anything else we want the
system to stop down starting from the
president to the Prime Minister to
everybody else we need the Parliament
new Parliament elected by the public the
city's old Holiday Inn stands still has
a scar of what this place has seen but
for people here it's also a reminder
that their political class hasn't
changed in the 30 years since the Civil
War ended
the politicians have got richer the
people have got poorer religious of
political divides have festered but no
more maybe people were previously
fearful to critique their political
leaders in their own communities and now
they are standing against them
courageously chanting against corruption
against the old political guard for 24
hours there's been no word from the
government but the politicians can't
possibly hope this will go away it
really doesn't feel like it will mark
stone Sky News in Beirut